[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
happy thanksgiving a tradition like no
other eat a huge meal
watch the first half of a game and be
passed out by 215.
welcome to the squad ride brought to you
by draftkings live in the bluetooth
report app
my name is cabbie richards our big bank
and betting expert is in the middle that
is kelly stewart
and the only way to get in his good
books is to offer up
winners only please
that is greg ivory before we start the
show happy 23rd birthday kelly
happy 23rd thank you guys you're very
welcome
all right so this is the show where we
bet anytime touchdowns
and we ride with the players selected by
you the audience
we're eight and three on the season and
the gambling gods
answered the prayer from silly man last
week because aaron jones
scored a touchdown on those cults so
thank you very much sir we asked you
to um we asked you for your picks to
score a touchdown on thanksgiving
got a ton of great responses and these
are the most popular picks that we
received
have a look got a couple of studs from
the ohio stand up there
zeke elliott and terry mclaren and a
couple of rookies on the board
antonio gibson and deandre swift
excellent so we have four legendary
videos to show you
which will decide our thanksgiving squad
ride
before we do that here are some of our
favorite moments from the week
are any dogs in the house
[Music]
oh okay that's that he's gonna eat it
all but he went with cooper cup
anytime touch has four bring one back
girl what is it
there it is babies
[Music]
my grandma here is going to help me oh
we got the ezekiel elliott spoon
big celebrations listen uh gray's gonna
do his best marshawn lynch impression
but instead of
giving out turkeys for thanksgiving on
the street he's gonna be giving out
hoodies
right here in the app because he is our
bay legend
g-money it's time to tap in
it's time it is time it is time this is
right here is what i call
my handy-dandy ipad if you did not know
i'm in the comments cabbie
i am in the comments uh btap says
br greg's on the handy dandy ipad giving
away hoodies probably time for me
to sure swift gibson and mclaren
so i guess he's rocking with two two
picks in one i'll give him the parlay
there
you're walking away with a hoodie b tab
24 i got one more cabbie
uh j buck j buck
double zero two zero says terry mclaren
gibson and sam's i think he has the
trifecta there
they're throwing them out there in the
comments jay buck you're walking
you're walking away with a hoodie uh
cabbie
i'm done i'm done in the comments right
now i'm done in the comments right now
i'll get back to it though i'll
definitely get back to it excellent all
right well listen we have a
we have a shorter version of the
tournament with only two games on
thanksgiving but the squad is gonna ride
with
whoever you choose uh the last video
standing is our squad ride so let the
tournament begin
our first pitch comes from felide 37 and
is sous chef
who you got mama i need your help
yep i'm on a really bad cold streak
right now and i need you to
whoop up you know something hot anytime
touchdown score what do you think
zeke elliott you heard it here first
folks
zeke ellie anytime score elliot let's go
anytime touchdown score
love those collaborations those are my
favorite um
are his opponent is eric friedman who's
back in the mix
eric who do you have in round one
thursday night is
thanksgiving football we need your help
on our anytime touchdown score bet
all right i'm listening i need you to
choose between brandon cooks
will fuller marvin jones and tj
hawkinson
and whatever you choose we're riding
with all right we're going with fuller
i i love that uh eric is out there just
recruiting people for the squad rod
gotta love and also probably gonna
murder a couple of frosties tonight
thank you for that
uh so you've heard the first two pitches
ezekiel elliott and will
fuller tell us in the comments who
comments who is a lock to score
touchdown
on thanksgiving greg what'd you think of
those two videos
cabbie i'm actually back and forth here
i i want to talk about the microphone
i'm the microwave legend
the microwave legend and ezekiel elliott
picked first the excitement on mom's
face once she saw it was zeke
and she lifted the excitement got me i i
felt that i i
i now i'm now confident zeke might score
so i'm actually liking the minus 143 and
the ezekiel
uh elliott pick but let's talk about the
frosty legend and the will fuller pig
i mean my guy pulled up to wendy's and
he asked the question
to the to the employee and the employee
was so
adamant he was very confident in his
pick he was
very confident in the will filler pick
so that has me thinking like wow
like he's confident he might know an
inside scoop or something so cabbie i
don't know i don't know i gotta talk to
kelly
kelly talk to me will fuller ezekiel
elliott what are you thinking greg
you're always killing me on this show
all right look zeke is a short price
here i mean just a few short weeks ago
you're laying
two dollars or more to bet on zeke well
zinc had some fumble itis
zeke's been seeing the ball a little bit
less thanks to our dude tony pollard
andy dalton's been throwing the ball a
little bit more but i don't think he's
gonna be throwing the ball this week
against that
uh washington pass rush so i think zeke
has a good shot here
to score a touchdown plus with that
draftkings odds boost you're getting a
great price
on the flip side you have will fuller
one of the best wide receivers on the
texans team going up against
some really bad defensive backs
on the lions we know they love to give
up the deep ball so
honestly i like both these picks but if
you're gonna have to make me choose i
gotta go with my dude zeke
okay uh g-money i guess
are we are we calling that or we're
sorry we we gotta we gotta hear what the
audience is saying my bad
cabbie cabbie you know you know the
handy-dandy ipad has to come out and we
gotta dive into these comments
um i got saljeet
rashwami saying will fuller is having a
field
day rocking with will fuller you're
walking away with a hoodie
uh i got tick boot pierce 20 said
i'm going with fuller all day zeke's
playing a slick nasty washington
defense rocking with fuller cabbie the
next one
i see i'm gonna go with it okay i'm just
gonna scroll and then the next the next
one i see
we're gonna go with it okay here we go
cabbie
we got young pittsburgh zeke is the lock
nothing from the red rifle this game
he's
riding with zeke i'm riding with zeke
kelly's riding with zeke so i'm making
the call cabbie
zeke is moving on to the next round all
right so
we are riding with zeke thank you to
felide37
your sous chef the microwave legend you
are
moving on past round two the contest
isn't over moving on to round two
the contest isn't over yet here we go uh
next up for the fourth week in a row
riley sorbo our local our local farmer
friend
came through with another video who you
got this week riley
squad ride pick em thanksgiving edition
ambrose is our little helper today all
righty
let's get this money ready ambrose hey
ready
bring it back what do we got
oh antonio gibson
gobble gobble baby lock it in
appreciate you riley servo greg what do
you think of like the consistent
quality videos that riley produces every
week for the squad ride
i'm loving it cabbie but listen here at
first we had the chickens
then we went to the gecko and now
we see a dog that kind of that kind of
i don't know how i feel about that i was
expecting a tiger or a lion or something
you know
i was expecting to go big i don't have
half the season though but
you're right you're right you're right
but with that being said
the pick the pick um i don't really know
if i like this one it's sitting at plus
100
i don't know if i i would play this but
i know somebody who has more insights
and that's kelly
kelly talk to us i got plenty of insight
on this game but i don't want to give
out because
it's my best bet look again i think this
is a really short price on zeke
and i do think that the cowboys will
have to focus on their running game here
speaking of running game is the
washington football team gonna focus on
their running game
yes a little bit but i think they're
really starting to let alex smith
air it out out here especially against
this dallas cowboys secondary
so i don't know if we're gonna see a
touchdown from gibson here
i'm going to go with zeke
all right uh g money yeah how's the
the audience reacting to this one
larson actually he added you on this
when he said elliott all the way at
cabbie richards
he's letting you know cabbie that he's
riding with
zeke uh harper harper harper rimmer
still zeke alex smith as
uh alex smith as a running back
he has jd mckissick i have to go
with uh mr feed zeke so he uh harper's
riding with zeke
uh kevin i got one more one more one
more in me one more emmy
i'm looking one more in me uh
i got i got jay webb saying you already
know
it's ezekiel elliott cavi i just made a
decision
the people made a decision in the handy
dandy ipad kelly made her decision
we are all riding with ezekiel elliott
in the microwave legend second round
sweep well done
felide 37 you continue on to the final
round
whoever we named whoever wins this next
round is our thanksgiving squad ride
so let's get it our final match up our
final pitch
is from p kelly 17 with a young foghorn
leghorn
all right i got my girl mcnugget here
she's gonna give us our thanksgiving
lock of the day anytime touchdown score
we got chase claypool deshawn watson
terry mclaurin city lamb lamar jackson
and danny amendola
let's see what happens
scary terry
i think i think scary terry is terry
rozier but tara mclaren
is the pick from uh foghorn leghorn
there our mcnugget
legend uh g-money what'd you think of
that
cabbie i mean it's thanksgiving a
chicken is
basically a baby turkey i mean they even
have the little dangly stuff underneath
their neck just like the turkeys
so i'm loving this pic not only am i i'm
loving the video
yeah yeah yeah not only am i loving the
video
i actually like this pic scary terry
plus
135. i'm loving that i
i mean kelly talk to me we got scary
terry plus 135 ezekiel elliott -143
what are you thinking where are you
leaning talk to me
i actually think both guys are gonna
score a touchdown
on thanksgiving but terry mclaren
is going to have himself a day against
that dallas secondary they've given up
the most
touchdowns in the air over any other
team that's
24 on the season my dude is scoring a
touchdown on thursday
all right so uh yes yes yes uh get in
the comments
vote for our winner boom boom boom boom
boom while you do that
the indianapolis colts cashed last week
in overtime
which added another bad another bag to
kelly's win total
so salute to the colts for your for the
uh
best bet kelly uh here we are on
thanksgiving
who do you have as your thanksgiving
best bet
i tried not to give it away during the
other parts of the show but i am on the
washington football team
plus three now i know it's going down at
two and a half in some spots so you can
always throw them
in a teaser spot for another game on
sunday but
look bottom line i'm taking the better
defense plus the points here andy dalton
had a nice bounce back
against the vikings and that's fine and
all but now we're going to a divisional
underdog here this game should be
a pick em because guess what the
washington football team is coming away
with the win out of dallas and they are
gonna be cruising in first place in the
nfc
east also worth noting that antonia
gibson has scored five touchdowns in his
last four games so get on draftkings
lock in that pick washington plus two
and a half
plus three uh as and the football team
is looking to complete
its season sweep of the dallas cowboys
okay so thank you very much for that
best bet kelly stewart
much appreciated we're we're rocking
we're uh
g-money i think it's that time in the
show
where the decision has been made by the
audience but you got to let us know
who we're riding with in the
thanksgiving squad ride
i got you cabs i'm laughing i'm actually
laughing at the comments
i got cw bear they say uh cowboy
secondary secondary could not stop
cabbie or greg mclaren all
the way you're walking away with a
hoodie uh
i see terry i see scary terry i see
terry i see scary cabbie i i i should
call it but i want to give away some
more hoodies so
l-l-z-t-y-g-a-z-l-l i'm
that person that's for the producers
scary terry's gonna cook them up
you're walking away with a hoodie uh
i think that's it for right now cabbie i
think that's it for right now i think we
get
we get we get the idea scary terry
is who the squad is riding with gary
terry is who the squad is riding with
cabbie you see it on the graphic right
there he's at plus 135
can we please switch that graphic can we
please
push the graphic thank you there it is
that's the music i want to hear
plus 300. we are riding with scary terry
tomorrow on the squad ride make sure you
guys
check us out on the br betting instagram
channel but remember not gonna say it i
want you guys to say it in the
comments say it in the comments i'll
give out some hoodies okay
uh also uh check out vr betting social
for the link to the odds boost send us
to screw your screenshots
of your bets and also finish the line
for g-money you guys know what the line
is
but congratulations to the mcnugget
legend and terry mclaren
for being our thanksgiving squad ride
send us your videos and your
celebrations if you're if you're still
awake after a full thanksgiving dinner
that might that tryptophan might trip
you up but either way
if you can send us those celebrations
because we want winners
um listen congrats to all our hoodie
winners uh thank you to everybody who
commented on a thanksgiving
uh thursday and uh thank you to our
legends eric friedman
uh fellaini 37 riley sorbo and p
kelly 17 uh the mc and your mcnut
nugget legend everybody else who
submitted videos thank you
you'll have a chance to be a legend next
week jim money what do you got
you see what this is this is called the
handy dandy ipad and i see
some people replying back to me so that
means we're going to have to give them
hoodies because that's what they are
here for
madeleine you're walking away with a
hoodie uh winners only please mikey
draco you're walking away with a hoodie
z fits you are also walking away with a
hoodie
uh cabbie can i keep on going uh uh
western wizard you're walking away with
a hoodie
soren jay you're walking away what are
you cabbie i'm done okay i'm done
i'm done y'all i think you i think you
ain't getting in a bit uh hoodie last
week you're too generous to money
but obviously the audience always
appreciates it and we appreciate the
quality of the videos
getting better and better each week so
continue to level up
thank you very much for that listen
alongside uh kelly stewart our betting
expert
and please send this man winners only
please that is gregory my name is cabby
richards um
keep an eye out for our picks on sunday
later this week
otherwise we'll see you back here for uh
for lucky
week number 13. this has been the squad
ride talk to you soon peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you